boeing has issued a public apology for
two crashes involving the same aircraft
model within the last six months which
claimed a total of 346 lives we at
Boeing are sorry for the lives lost in
the recent 737 max accidents the history
of our industry shows most accidents are
caused by a chain of events this again
is the case here
Dennis Muhlenberg went on to say that
the Ethiopian Airlines incident in March
and the Indonesian crash in October were
both caused by the same technical
malfunction the disasters involved a
Boeing 737 max which is an anti stalling
feature called the maneuvering
characteristics augmentation system the
CEO explained that in both cases that
system had reacted to incorrect data
causing the noses of the plane to be
forced down when the pilots were trying
to gain altitude now the you open
Airlines jet was traveling from Addis
Ababa to Nairobi there was 147 people on
board from 35 countries the pilots had
reported difficulties with the aircraft
and were granted a return to the airport
they were unable though to regain
control according to a preliminary
report from the Ethiopian authorities
the pilots followed Boeing's guidelines
we can now cross live to Jacques Astra
aviation security expert thanks for
joining us sir good to have you on the
program today
obviously the apologies have come today
from the Boeing CEO he said he's sorry
for the lives lost but the company does
can remain confident and the fundamental
safety of that particular model how
confident do you think passengers will
be do you think there's going to be a
reluctance now to for people to get on
that plane unfortunately this is not a
new phenomenon their past accidents that
has taken place for almost the same
reason different technology and while
those airplanes survives the reputation
that was caused by the accidents so will
Boeing 737 max it's the issue is
fundamentally due to the according to
the
News reports the angle-of-attack
sensor as the case there are previous
accidents that had that resulted in the
same type of accident and the airplanes
one being the Lockheed l-1011 and the
other being an Airbus a310 both survives
the repercussions of the accidents the
issue right now is if in fact it's the
angle of attack and sensor it raises the
issue that that is apparently a common
cause of several accidents not just the
77 max so if six is to replace those
sensors and with with sensors that are
more reliable than unfortunately it's
the sensor and not actually the aircraft
that's the problem a lot of a lot of
crashes are obviously caused by human
error by pilot error but according to
the preliminary reports at least the
crew had performed all the procedures
repeatedly provided by Boeing but was
still not able to get control of the
aircraft
does this make matters worse for Boeing
no not necessarily because what we don't
know is if in fact the procedures were
followed and carried out completely to
the fullest extent from the information
that I've heard and again these are from
news reports that in fact the system was
turned off and then turned back on again
raises some serious questions the we
don't know is were previous reports
considering the same issue
did it happen to the same airplane prior
to the accident and that's another piece
of information
to know about in the case of lawyer we
know that there were three previous
incidents that occurred for the accident
took place and we also know that prooves
react acted it's the same problem prior
to the accident that took place the
question I have right now is well was
there a repeat problem that took place
with pink rash and then my next question
is did in fact the crew carry out the
maneuvers to the fullest extent that
needed to be taken or did they do
something in the interim that allowed
the system to continue the problem until
the airplane crash and that's my
question
and I asked that question not as a in
any type of journalistic fashion my
question is from a accident
investigative perspective indeed and
hopefully more decent reports will come
out in future which will give us an
insight into the reasons exactly behind
that crash Jacques Astra aviation
security expert thanks for your time
today here in RT International
you